en
douceur justin qui
touche c'était mon meilleur ami
maternelle c'est le mec le plus gentil
que je dise est invité par la mariée ou
le mile en fait j'ai dégusté le marié
demain je vais y aller et lui demander
devant tous les invités s'il est
vraiment sûr depuis
le jour de son mariage c'est sûr de ton
coup c'est peut-être un peu trop tard
je viens de me marier
c'est différent dans un autre univers il
en existe des millions
[Musique]
c'est à dire
j'ai comme une impression
j'ai vécu son
rêve et je suis un mariage et je suis
sûr que je fais déjà vu ici te
présentant un veau né le monde d'accord
enfin tout à moi aussi j'ai fait un très
bon ami ray quoi tu veux construire des
sites justement il faut que je reste je
dois faire un truc hyper important
salut mon lit je croyais plutôt mariage
à aujourd'hui oui je passe une bonne
journée avec moi même si je m'endors
maintenant tu auras oublier cette
journée et la journée d'avant
tu devais penser à un truc vraiment
merdique non c'est
qui fait l'amour avec nos colloques et
je n'ai pas fait qu'une seule fois mais
plein de fois
et toi est-ce que tu laisses je sais pas
mais aussi beaucoup je te demande de
quitter ce mariage est une perversion
temps
j'ai dit la vérité si l'espèce parier
c'est leur décision
mais qu'est ce qui ne tourne pas rond
chez toi
dis moi ce que je suis censé faire rien
à part souris
[Musique]